thank you so for the record I'm
representative Tony lekkis uh
representing Hillsboro 38 the towns of
Hudson and Litchfield so
um
this is the
sort of
cleanup and some minor modifications as
I presented before
um there's there was the amendment I
presented before and the related to
teacher job sharing
um the uh
Nea lobbyist is looking for an
additional change which actually makes
sense that the thing is that uh a lot of
cases this is uh
you know people that have either other
jobs or they're taking care of kids and
so how the uh
uh the breakdown of who works what hours
um can vary and the the bill and then
the initial amendment was 50 50 and it's
not always 50 50.
um the uh
and this the uh you know Marty from the
Retirement Systems here he said they're
okay with it they don't want to go too
far so you know somebody's not working a
tiny number of hours but uh
I think you have a copy of the proposed
amendment and on this one
um what I'd suggest if the committee is
okay with it to uh to vote to at least
in principle accept this I can get an
amendment drafted and then when we do
the exec and the full committee I'll
have that there if if that's okay
and then there's the other parts of it
and I mean I don't have anything to say
but I'll be glad to answer questions on
okay thank you Marty's here if you have
questions from the retirement system but
um you know they said it's acceptable
and
does anybody need to ask any questions
of the
no
all right and that being the case I
don't want to belabor this one too much
more we've talked about it pretty
extensively
um I would like to move
uh the adoption of this proposed
amendment uh and then move out to pass
as amended
all right all those in favor
okay
so this bill deals with um the
firefighter Academy we do have an
amendment to extend it to the police
academy as well
um did anybody have anything that they
yes representative true
thank you Mr chair uh
I think I have a problem with including
the
the amendment uh including the police
academy
um
the police academy is staffed full-time
I'm a little concerned with my limited
knowledge of uh weakening the retirement
system and its funding
by allowing
people to come in and work part-time
because they'll be working and not
um
so I don't I don't think I could I would
not be able to support the police
um
I have my problems other problems with
the bill sure but that that I think is
my objection with my limited knowledge
of how the pension system works uh for
the amendment to uh to allow the police
academy to do the same okay and the
thank you Mr chair I know I'm not a
member but I'd just like to make a few
comments
um my concern is with the bill
we didn't hear a number of exact number
of how many retired firefighters are
working
at the Academy
we don't have figures on how many of
those members who are working are up
against the 24-hour
time 26 hour time frame and until we
have those numbers no I mean if this
bill is only going to affect
we heard there were roughly 75 percent
full-time firefighters working at the
Academy 25 percent
retirees
but we don't have exact numbers as to
and if this legislation is only going to
affect
five
ten instructors
I mean we're passing legislation from
five or ten people and I'm not sure we
want to go there versus looking to
increase the pool of
instructors they have up there so I mean
until we get those numbers it's kind of
hard to work on the bill and knowing if
it's going to be effective if we don't
have numbers now
to compare with numbers passing
legislation
then how do we know if it even did what
they were looking for and that's that's
my concern with this on top of
increasing the hours which we like I
said is going to be a Snowball Effect
they came in now you got the police
academy who's going to be next in line
looking for their hours increased and it
bothers me to go down that road thank
you thank you uh and I agree
um that's why I'm actually going to move
uh that we retain this bill at the
present time I just think that there are
too many questions that we asked that we
didn't have answers to
um there are are available hours for the
retired firefighters to work at the
Academy but they're not taking those
hours they're splitting it with other
areas I want to know why that is is it a
rate of pay issue are they paying less
at the fire economy I think there are
other potential solutions that we can
look into be more than happy to work
with the fire academy towards some
solutions and by retaining this bill we
keep it in our working purview and we
can have those conversations hopefully
get some of those answers that we don't
have and make sure that the solution
that we're coming to is the right one uh
for the reasons the representative
Goldie mentioned we are opening a can of
worms if we just push forward with this
um to other areas other groups of people
and I'm really hesitant to do that
personal
so I'm going to move that we retain HB
and I will just call a vote on that and
all in favor
all right we'll move in that direction
at this point then and then we'll um see
what kind of information we can get with
that I'll close the subcommittee meeting
it was real quick one this morning and
okay good morning everybody happy
February
and I'd like to open the public hearing
on House Bill 519 and call
uh thank you madam chairman
um
this is a little unusual would would you
have any problem with Mr Galla the
commissioner of doit coming up not at
all all right
all right so this bill was at his
request
um okay so
um I'm representative Jess Edwards uh
good morning happy February I think is
the saying of the morning so I uh I'm
I'm here representing Rockingham
District 31 that's Auburn Candia
Chester and Deerfield uh I'm here to
introduce House Bill 519 with an FN it's
relative to establishing a chief
information security officer for the
Department of Information Technology
um this this bill uh is
predominantly at the request of the
Chief Information
officer of of the state
um uh he and I have taught been talking
to each other now for almost six years
about I.T strategy and the like and so I
think we've developed a collegial
relationship
uh I don't think anyone can argue that
in this era of cyber security
vulnerabilities and penetrations that
having a really competent experience
trained individual in information
security there you are how are you
representative true
uh that that that is just vital to
protecting the privacy and security of
our data so the so that's that's the
obvious point the good news is that the
Commissioners already hired this hired
this person to do this so what what are
we doing here what we're really doing is
we're putting the
um sort of the framework for what this
person's responsible for and accountable
for into the statute so that so that
there's just a stronger underpinning of
of what needs to be taking place and I
particularly like the governance and and
uh and risk uh program part of it that's
on the second page uh starting on line
10.
um I I think if I had looked at it and
thought about it a little bit more I
would have wanted to put privacy in
there too but but I I I trust that this
governance committee will be established
in the right way so so I I can take
questions but the the real person who
knows things is the commissioner
thank you representative Edwards I have
a question if you don't have this
position in statute how did you hire
somebody
yes
yeah because the commissioner
represented
uh good morning I'm Madam chair members
of the committee uh my name is Dennis
Goulet I am the commissioner for the
Department of Information Technology
um when I joined
um the state in 2015 May of 2015. we
already had a chief information security
officer that position had been
um it was a it was an unclassified
position that had been filled by my
predecessor
um that we are now on our third Chief
Information secure security officer
since that position was established in
doit I believe that was what happened
there was a an unclassified former DHHS
position was brought to the the jcec and
was was established as the ciso what was
missing and what we're trying to repair
here is the you know the definition in
statute the authorities and
responsibilities in statute for that so
so that we've had a pretty
high level robust cyber security
function
um we're one of the leaders in the in
the nation in that respect
um but we were we have been missing the
codification of the actual
responsibility so that's what that's
what I would like to address with this
legislation
thank you that makes me feel better uh
any other questions representative
Luckett said then Simon thank you yeah I
noticed that there was nothing explicit
about privacy in here and I was going to
ask you about that but you anticipated
it and uh if if you know you want to
talk to me we can do an amendment to
take care of that
um if I could I would like to address
that
um so
um where we're seeing States go in in
fact corporations uh all entities
security and privacy are too pretty
different things and so
I actually asked for a Chief privacy
officer function in the governor's
budget I don't know if whether that will
be funded or not in the governor's
budget but I've also told the governor
that I've talked to some folks including
representative Edwards about the need
for a privacy function in the state and
so if it's not funded in the governor's
budget I would be asking for it in
division one Finance as well when I'm
thank you madam chair uh just real quick
on the fiscal impact so this is a
position that already exists will there
be any fiscal impact or not no they sent
me a fiscal note request and I sent back
a zero dollar FN and and so
um there's the the position itself
um I have a ciso who's as I said has
been around for over a decade and was uh
I think back in um 2016 I did bring the
position to the jcec again to get an
increase in Pay but we're still of
course not close to Market in fact I
think
uh I was recently interviewing for this
position and we were seeing the folks on
the on the private sector Market were
earning between three and four hundred
thousand a year which of course I'm not
paying uh anything close to that
thank you for being here
how many
is it just one position
uh there is a a chief information
security officer I also have a deputy
one of the challenges that states have
is it's a difficult position to retain
because it's such a hot commodity in the
market right now so I've been very
fortunate my last two cisos have been
ex-military so they've been retired and
taking a pension as well as getting paid
by the state there's a deputy and then
there's
um three other people in that department
who are doing the day-to-day cyber
security operations I also have a
contract with a with an outside company
who does seven by twenty four 365
monitoring of all the end points in in
uh in the state as well
follow on yes follow-up
follow-up
is
there a reason why we're not
project and why I'm asking this question
is that I am
fairly well versed
from an aerospace and defense industry
Viewpoint and when I log into my
legislative email there's no third party
authentication at all
it goes right literally goes right
through
and I would think that from a government
and state aspect that we are the most
vulnerable also that when you hire a
team of people
the changes in the cyber security
industry are coming so fast and furious
that having a subcontracted service in
my opinion is is much better and you're
not paying retirement and everything
else thank you okay there were there
were a couple parts to that I'll I'll
address the first one which was
um the you know my my domain is the
executive branch so so we do we do have
um multi-factor authentication
implemented for
um for most of the access in in the
executive branch and and email and
collaboration being one
um the we actually have a really tiny
staff that manages multiple contracts
one of them so I'd say we're heavily
outsourced not completely outsourced
even when you're fully outsourced you
still need a management function that
maintains the contracts and things like
that so so for example we have the 7 by
24 365 monitoring of all our systems
which is outsourced we have um Regular
cyber risk assessments which is
outsourced our third-party cyber risk
assessments that come in and assess
applications and practice and things
like that we have contracts for um
outside contracts for uh incident
response so should we have an incident
we need to bring in expertise whether it
be legal or technical or whatever so I
I'd say we're probably
um you know in terms of cyber operations
perspective and cyber strategy we're
yeah and and if I may it just I want to
I want to add on to that and so I think
the commissioner just did a nice job of
of addressing your point there and to
your point yeah there's a lot of
Reliance on Outsourcing to to give us
everything we need
um I what the power of this bill is
primarily in my view is that uh to use
an army metaphor this is the mission
statement this this is what the
legislature uh and once it's signed by
the governor this is this this is the
legislative uh Charter to the
commissioner to ensure that these things
are getting done and and you know
without a clerk without Clarity in the
mission then there's some ambiguity on
exactly what our expectations are this
gives us an opportunity to clearly
communicate what our expectations are so
that then there's a dependence on on
their part to to get it done so so to me
that's a huge value in this bill is just
it we need to tell them what we what we
thank you representative Edwards
representative Gerhart
thank you madam chair
as far as the report's assessments and
other things are discussed in the bill
goes are these available to the public
I'm just worried about reports that get
filed but nobody ever sees them there's
no oversight
um thank you that's a good question
um we have the information Technology
Council which has
um
representation for two house members are
represented and our cyber strategy
as well as if we have a you know reports
or things that we need to do we can go
into non-public session and the house
members and the other members of the I.T
Council are able to review and hold us
accountable for dealing with
vulnerabilities I think if if you wanted
to dig into it you find you'd find that
we take our any vulnerabilities that we
do find very seriously additionally
we're almost continuously being audited
by the federal government multiple
entities inside the federal government
and in different ways too from a cyber
security and a privacy perspective so so
we're like SSA Social Security
Administration we just got done one of
those and we'll be going into one with
the health and human services from uh
Center for Medicaid Medicare Services
CMS and and we also have PCI audits
annually that's payment card industry
because we do a lot lot of payment card
business particularly the largest area
there would be the Liquor Commission so
we're almost continuously being audited
I actually have a compliance person who
manages the function inside doit of
being audited and responding to audit
findings if they come up
follow up so my job is to State the
obvious the blinding flash of the
obvious and and so to the point of
public reporting there there's a fine
line right where where yes there's
public transparency but you don't also
don't want to publish your
vulnerabilities because that's the those
are the keys to the kingdom so so that
they they do have a way to keep that
information uh open to the right people
without making that public and I and I
do think there's an expectation that we
don't want to make it all public to
begin with
and if I could if I could add to that
and then I'll I'll take your your
follow-up there's also an exclusion in
91a
thank you madam chair okay I I just
personally don't have much faith in the
federal government especially
considering the southern border I mean
is you know for them being oversight
capacity for the state seems kind of
you know I wouldn't credit that but the
point is
there's no way to have some kind of
redacted report given to the public it
just seems kind of odd to me you have a
we have a public position supposed to be
doing a public job the public is not
aware of what's going on at least
there's there must be some way to
provide some information to the public
of what this person is doing
that's what I'm saying it has to be some
um today we haven't publicized
are the reports that are given by Third
parties we do we do publicly publish our
strategy and
um on our website and and any activities
we're taking and and we've been pretty
uh transparent too when we have found
vulnerabilities that required us to for
example some of you may remember we shut
down a whole bunch of Environmental
Services uh system some years ago when
we found a large number uh some fairly
significant vulnerabilities there and we
I'd publicly address that saying to to
the folks who have impacted folks
look we found a vulnerability we didn't
want to leave it open so I took the
systems down in collaboration with the
commissioner of Environmental Services
we are prioritizing the the remediation
of each one of those and items and
bringing them back live as soon as
possible and we did that out of even
though we you know I apologize for the
inconvenience to the public which of
course is important but also we want to
make sure we did protect their data so I
I feel like we are pretty transparent uh
up to a point where we as uh
representative Edwards says up to the
point where we don't um you know hand
Technology Council which is closely
involved with what the oit does and how
it performs and there are
representatives of the public namely a
couple of Representatives and two
senators
right right and and if I think if uh if
we if we wanted to make it clear that
there is a public-facing reporting
requirement a a way to consider doing
that is on line 10 of page two where it
lays out what this uh security
governance and risk program is about we
could make you know consider adding an
echo paragraph sub paragraph it just
says something to the extent of uh
ensuring appropriate public reporting
because these meetings these governance
meetings will have both things that
could be public and things that should
not ever be public and but they could
make that divide and and try to provide
the level of transparency that would
achieve that compromise I think does
that sound I we just made that up yeah
no I'd be happy to amend that another
possible Amendment too I've been wanting
to have more reps on the information
Technology Council a larger number we
have two and and I feel like I'd rather
have four or estate reps on the
information Technology Council that way
I could know I'd always have two or
three attending each meeting because
schedules are hard to jockey so we could
consider if we end up amending language
on this to for reporting maybe we would
want to amend to add two more reps to
the information Technology Council
thank you very much representative
Schmidt you had a question
no I have another one Madam chair so if
we're going to amend it is it a is it
going to go to a subcommittee
huh
if it needs to be amended then yes it
will go to subcommittee which will go to
representative barotas okay well an
organization so we ought to
I think we ought to get on board with
all this amendment talk that we're
appearing because uh
some of it is needs to be done
representative I'll defer to you well
representative
by adding all this stuff
to a bill
that just is a simple bill
making things complicated can't we just
pass the bill as it is and then you can
add it whatever you need to to your
Council in a separate I just don't want
this to become a bunch of stuff that
isn't related to the topic
so that my I'm just asking the question
um well I I am
I'm not uh either way rather whether
this gets amended or not I'm going to
add some kind of regular reporting
to to the duties of the ciso and and
using the I.T Council Information
Technology Council as a vehicle for said
reporting I think it's a it's a good
it's a good catch that
um representative Gerhard brought up and
I think that we you know to the extent
that we don't overdo how much
information we share I think reporting's
fine so I'm going to do that regardless
of what ends up in this bill all right
well if it doesn't need to be in statute
then I'm
um with representative Groton not
necessarily putting it into statute
representative AdWords so the question
is really kind of one of what's the
appropriate legislative strategy and and
now that I've introduced the bill the
bill belongs to the committee I'd
certainly defer to the chair and the
committee to what you want to do I just
want to let you know I I'm continuing
I'm willing to continue to help in
whatever way would facilitate getting
this bill passed I hope at its core you
see this is a good and necessary Bill
and you can support it and um and and I
think to your point representative you
know sometimes less is more we you know
maybe this is the good first start yeah
okay other questions representative
goalie
thank you madam chair and and that was
one of my concerns is if we try in
increase the membership on the council
we would probably with that Amendment
need another public hearing because I'm
not sure that that would be Jermaine and
my I believe you're correct question
would be you know if
we have to let's bring in a separate
piece of legislation for that next year
I don't think it's needed at this time
just to get this going forward this is
an early bill I don't know exactly where
it's going but I believe it would be
Finance
and adding more people to the council is
certainly something that could be done
in this bill in finance or in the budget
representative Schmidt thank you madam
chair I didn't get my second question in
uh um so you mentioned the jcec
situation earlier commissioner
as a one of the members of the jcec as a
matter of fact the only one that's
appointed at the moment uh you do have a
questionnaire in the system at the
moment because I think we ought to
proceed with that if we possibly can
once we get the jcec set up
um well I do have a couple things I'm
going to bring before the jcec but not
not this position this position is
already
um where it needs to be with respect to
that okay thanks good to know
any other questions
all right thank you very much gentlemen
thank you is there anyone else who
all right seeing none I will close the
public hearing
and
if we have time to accept okay without
objection we'll go into executive
session is there a motion
representative I move ought to pass on
second uh this bill
okay we have a motion ought to pass by
Reverend Lucas do you wish to speak to
your motion I do
um
you know having this
I mean you need
to have a an overall organized plan and
someone monitoring it and updating it to
even know if you're okay in the in
regards to security so I think having
this uh position and the definition of
Duties is is important
thank you representative Schmidt do you
wish to speak to your second no I think
that that we ought to proceed as quickly
as possible to get that we we've heard
repeatedly over the years that the state
is
being attacked literally thousands of
times every day by outside sources and
we
can't leave any stone unturned thank you
thank you does anyone else wish to speak
questions representing Gerhard
thank you madam chair I'm a little bit
confused as to the rush since this
position already exists and it's
operating at this time the position is
not the rush is not for the position but
for the bill it we this is an early Bill
we need to vote it out of committee no
later than next week
so
I'll add that we have a lot of bills
takes up exact next week so if we can
get anything done today is a good idea
okay anyone else thank you
representative Schmidt for your your
support
anyone else
all right seeing none the motion by
representative Lucas is ought to pass
and the clerk can call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
lakis yes representative Bailey
yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative Aber yes
representative Gerard yes
the clerk votes yes representative
grotta yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
schuette yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
and the chair yes
18 years
consent does anyone object to consent
the motion passes 18-0
foreign
it does not have a large dollar amount
it's small enough to be consider it
negligible
okay
yeah and I I'm I'm not sure but I think
it's Finance one never knows
okay
I'll represents of like I said report in
your earliest convenience
foreign
authorizing the Department of Revenue
Administration to incorporate the New
Hampshire Equalization manual and to the
administrative rules and I would like to
welcome representative McGuire
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee House Bill 285 is a joint
request
by the Department of Revenue
Administration
and the gel car committee
um
as representative Schmidt knows and many
but many of you have not had the
opportunity to discover
our administrative rules process forbids
a department from incorporating by
reference
a document that they produce
because if they are producing it and
they want it to be in rules and apply
then it should go through rulemaking
however in this case
the
Equalization manual is developed by the
assessing Standards Board which had been
an independent entity and it is now
attached to the Department of Revenue
they want to continue using that manual
because all the assessors are familiar
with it it's in assessing language and
they don't want to
put it into legalese for the benefit of
rules
but because that would be to the first
to be a lot of work and secondly would
be to make it less useful
for the uh
for the people who actually have to use
it namely the assessors
so
um
the fact that it wasn't
not that they wanted to incorporate by
reference was strongly supported by gel
car but we need we need to give them
explicit exemption from the the normal
rules to
allow it so House Bill 285 does that it
says that even though the assessing
Standards Board is now attached to
revenue assessment they can still
use refer to the assessing standards
manual
and attach it by reference
it keeps things the way they are
and
despite the reorganization of where the
board reports to and it is simpler and
easier for everybody involved so I hope
you will support it
any questions yes representative Lucas
um thank you what is the process for
updating the equalization manual who all
would have to approve any changes to
um and the assessing standards boards is
made up of who uh
it's a number of assessors the treasurer
I believe and representative Schmidt
will be able to answer that because he's
been on the assessing Standards Board
for a while okay follow-up yes the
reason I ask is that um
and I assume the the reason that um
rules should not reference outside
things is because
then it's not being approved by gelcoir
or the legislation legislature whatever
and I have the same concern potentially
for over this the assessing Standards
Board although it is administratively
attached to the Department of Revenue
assessment is not controlled by it and
the dra does not have very many members
on the board
all right it's a fairly independent
group
okay I'll wait until the more detailed
answer on who's on it
representative
did you have a question
yes I do have a question I just want a
confirmation so this basically
says that the current practices that are
being used by the assessing board and
the assessing manual will not change
just because the response where they
live is has changed
exactly thank you
yes and so what were the ramifications
be
if we did not have this legislation
then the assessing Standards Board would
have to
in the dra would have to put their
Equalization manual
as a rule adopted as a rule including
the formatting requirements
and representative do you have an
amendment with you for this I have an
amendment yes which is also at the
request of the dra and it simply
clarifies they already have it yes I
passed it around already this is
amendment zero zero eight six h
uh okay and it simply adds to their
duties
that they can develop the forms they
need
and that those forms or returns may be
required to be signed under the pain and
penalties of perjury
Mr chair yes point of order the
amendment isn't scheduled until 10 45
yeah I just recognized that I apologize
for that yeah I just don't want to get
ahead of ourselves yeah right fine so if
if I believe representative Schmidt
wants to speak on the basic bill and I
uh yes representatives to it yes
um representative McGuire was this bill
the original Bill requested by dra yes
thank you and agreed to buy gel car as
you can tell by the list of sponsors
because this is another instance where
it does not state that in the analysis
and I
the chair will call Representative
Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman for the record
Peter Schmidt representing Dover award
One Stratford 14. so uh
just as a little bit of background uh
the there used to be an equalization
Standards Board as well as an assessing
Standards Board
um I was on that for a while too until
it was done away with uh and now it's
kind of a subcommittee of the of the
assessing Standards Board
um but there there are a couple of
aspects involved here uh there's the the
gel car has a style and a manual that
requires specific language rules can't
be written just kind of willy-nilly all
over the place it there's a standard
manual for how rules have to be uh have
to be phrased and codified
and but in addition to this particular
thing for example the insurance industry
has a whole uh jargon if you will
um and they also incorporate some of
their Rules by reference so that so that
you don't wind up with something where
uh the the language that would all have
to be Rewritten to fit into the style
Manual of the gel car
and uh that that would be a lot of work
for one thing but it also uh would not
be all that understandable for the
industry which is used to kind of a
national jargon so anyway so
incorporating by reference really is
pretty vital to to have a continuity in
the particular specialized field of
dra in this case or Insurance in another
case
so anyway uh the the uh this the gel car
occasionally has situations where
particular Industries come before us
they want to incorporate something very
reference
um and it has to be vetted by the four
attorneys that we have uh in the
administrative rules unit who do the
background vetting of all these
um of all these rules so anyway it's
it's this is appropriate and as as
representation would ask in her question
it is requested by the dra
which still oversees some aspects of the
assessing Standards Board the rest of it
has been transferred previously just
relatively recently to under the oplc
and we'll get into that unless there's a
question thank you
yes representative likes thank you I
mean I'm not necessarily opposed to this
but I'd I'd like to be comfortable
understanding uh one thing and that is
um I think having rules go by gel car
and having the legislature involved in
okay and them is important
um and I don't know how changes the
equalization manual were handled before
and and who had to approve them
and how that might change as part of
this but I'm just trying to be assured
that in uh if this goes through that
it's still going to be the legislature
that has to approve any changes to this
Equalization manual if it's going to be
incorporated by reference into rules
I don't believe that there's that it
currently is the the requirement that
the legislature approved rules uh that's
what the gel car is for and that's why
we have professional attorneys to vet
the rules yeah I'm the gel car
representing the rest of the legislature
okay
on that premise yeah
yeah we we absolutely that's what the
gel car is all about it is a gatekeeper
that says we are giving the the
executive branch this is important for
everybody to understand uh the rules
have the force and effective laws okay
and and in in allowing the executive
branch to write rules
uh which have the force and effect of
law we are as the edge as the
legislature giving up a portion of our
our our prerogative power to the
executive branch
but obviously if there were no
gatekeeper involved the the executive
branch could
I could run all the wild but they could
they could they could get overboard and
so the gel car
that's all the rules that the the
executive branch produces because it is
that the various different agencies that
write the rules okay then they get
vetted by the four attorneys that we
currently have in the administrative
rules ruin it and but they can they only
have oversight up to a certain level if
there's some kind of a disagreement
if if I could interrupt I mean this is
not at all getting to my question until
if I could have a follow-up you can have
a follow-up thank you I understand all
that my my concern is uh understanding
how changes to the equalization manual
are approved and my concern is I want to
make sure that not the whole legislature
but you know something Joe car or
something similar is involved in
approving those changes if they're going
to be incorporated by reference as rules
well it would still have to go through
that that betting as I understand it uh
the the question is not whether it gets
seen the question of whether it has to
adhere to all the other gel car
requirements one of which is this
language situation it's not the content
so much as the way it's couched because
there's a lot of terms of Art in for
example if I could get follow-up yes
okay so
the question is
what is the process and who's involved
in approving changes to the equalization
manual is that gel car or somebody else
no the the the the the equalization
subcommittee of the ASB still operates
and and and in the realm of Equalization
I'm not on the equalization subcommit
anymore but it but it but it it still
gets seen But when the rules get
Incorporated they get Incorporated by
reference rather than having to adhere
to all the aspects of the gel car manual
okay follow-up I think yes I think I
might be getting to what I'm looking for
so
during their
it's included in Rules by reference so
it doesn't have to follow the format but
if there are changes in the
equalization manual does gel car itself
have to approve those changes
I think the answer is yes it was in
accurate to say that the gel car can
object to changes well we do ask for
when there is a major change to a
document by reference Joker asks for ex
and the agencies required to provide an
explanation of what changed why and why
it's necessary
follow-up yes so I you know I'm maybe
saying approved by is uh
inaccurate but at least if they're going
to be changed the manual with gel cars
still review it as they would review any
Rule and have the same rights to object
and you know even even put in a
resolution move back and all that okay
thank you I'm happy
it's not it's not an open door for them
to do anything they want that's for sure
yeah representative Payback
thank you Mr chair my question is what
caused
this bill to be drafted what was the
scenario that was the alarm to
the reason is that the assessing
Standards Board
we had a reorganization and the
assessing Standards Board is now an
independent
entity administratively attached to the
dra
that's a change in where it's
um where was it before well it
everything was under uh the dra before
but there was a particular problem and
that is that that assessors are overseen
by the
by the dra but that is the dra is kind
of a
I don't want to call it a puzzle Palace
but but it it has a lot of
confidentiality requirements where
things just you can't get at it because
of the nature of the revenue
Administration okay and one of the
things that was that was kept
confidential was evaluations of
assessors so if there are complaints and
so forth and so on
that went into this black box thank you
uh and that was never the legislature's
intent but that but in putting the the
assessing standard board under the uh
the dra that came with it that
confidentiality but we said that's not
what we want so we took most of the the
operations of the assessing Standards
Board out of the dra and put them under
oplc
so that so that the Assessors for
example would be and their operations
would be transparent to the public which
was always the intent of the legislature
and the confidentiality was something
that came with dra but was not something
that we wanted that's why we changed it
but in terms of one and I can't remember
exactly what it is that the dra still
oversees
thank thank you representative I
all right seeing none I'm going to close
the public hearing on HB 285 and open
6h and I think it might actually speak
this amendment is
was also a request to the dra which uh
they they asked me to put in while I was
talking about the uh
when I when I talked to them about the
bill itself they said oh well will you
take care of
um
this minor detail
and this is something that came out of
jail car
some of the dra forms
and returned ours are signed under the
looking at tax returns that seems
perfectly reasonable
and
that the rules of gel car require that
such a form be
needed to have specific approval
to or
that the uh the pains and penalties of
perjury apply to this to the particular
form
uh the dra is
thought it would be easier if they just
had a blanket exemption because nearly
all of their forms are signed under the
so they they asked for a blanket
exemption you'll notice this is in RSA
21j which is what defines the Department
they can ask they can if you sign a tax
return or something like that they can
assess they can go after you for perjury
or unsworn falsification or whatever
actually perjury perjury in this case
even if the form doesn't specifically
say so
and they think of this as a simple
cleanup
um I will try to answer it I'm
unfortunately my contact at dra has
another bill he's presenting at the
moment but the department did send out a
letter which I believe they sent to the
entire committee
in support of this amendment
questions
yes representative Lucas
um just are the currently now and I
assume this wouldn't change it are those
uh forms or returns
no that's one of the exemptions that uh
that the dra has they can change their
forms at any time
explicitly yes and so that's current
separate from this bill current and
separate absolutely thank you
seeing them thank you so much thank you
did anybody else wish to speak on HB 285
representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman
um so uh in response to the question it
was just asked I wanted to say that
um the the dra is a taxing entity is
subject in many of its
aspects to Federal uh preemption and so
forth
and it kind of acts as a pass-through
agencies to some degree for the for uh
IRS and because
forms that are issued by the IRS
have to be implemented
very quickly you know they have
deadlines and so forth uh and the the
rules process uh the vetting process is
somewhat time consuming and so they they
dra rules have to be very flexible to
into to
Encompass if you will or that's not a
good word uh the right way is not the
right word anyway it's a perfectly good
word
um but anyway they have to be flexible
in order to meet IRS deadline
requirements and so their rules uh in in
some regards are are exempt from the gel
guy process I was on a subcommittee
about 10 years ago that looked at that
particular aspect it was viewed to
changing it and they the tra came in and
said you're asking us to effectively
violate federal law and requirements so
we we have lots of things on gel car
where we're passing Federal requirements
through because it's
national law
so it's important to understand that
any questions
thank you representative anybody else
want to speak to the amendment
2023-80086
seeing none I will close the public
well without objection I'll go into
executive session
and I'll move lot to pass with Amendment
on House Bill 285.
yes no no no you have to have a motion
first
off did you want to second that
and I'd like to speak to the motion as I
as I said this is a request to the dra
it will simplify their processes
and give them Authority it doesn't cost
anything
um
it simply cleans up some of the statutes
and at their request
um I have nothing to add thank you okay
anyone else want to talk about
representative yeah
um I'll vote for the amendment I'm just
uh you know I understand the issue about
timeliness and and the FEDS but I am
concerned that uh
we're having forms created without
legislative oversight that people can be
you know can require information without
perjury threat so I'll look into that
yes I I agree it's something we should
it it definitely is a good idea that we
not just kind of like don't even look at
oh that's something so it's what's
um
this kind of legislation is determined
by the agency and the organization the
gel car which is a legislative body so
if they agree to these types of and
these are experienced people
experienced Representatives so who have
been on these committees for a long time
so I don't have any concern with these
types of requests if this was something
that was
put together
um
in in a expedient way I would have more
concerns but I think that the bill in
itself defines what we're doing and how
representative just just wondering if
the previous comment was related to the
amendment of the bill and the reason I
ask is that
uh you know my concern was around the
forms not being reviewed by childcare at
all
it was everything mm-hmm okay anyone
else
okay in that case the motion is to adopt
oh thank you representative
sorry a flag kind of hidden down here
um I just wanted to state that
currently I think probably the
foremost Representatives uh with
authority and knowledge of the processes
of gel car
our Representatives Maguire and Schmidt
so I will just say that if they're okay
just just in response to that I I agree
um so I'm taking advantage of their
knowledge to try and understand what's
going on here
okay
thank you and it never hurts to get an
extra eye or three on
on any agency
all right the motion is to adopt
Amendment zero zero eight six H to House
Bill 285 and the clerk can call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
Lucas yes representative Bailey yes
representative
yes representative true yes
representative Dolan yes representative
a bear yes representative Gerhard yes
the clerk votes yes
representative yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goli yes
representative schuette yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
and the chair yes
to pass with Amendment on House Bill 285
any further discussion
represent Simon yes representative
yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative abert yes
representative Gerhard yes look vote
Jess
representative groda yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative shuitt yes representative
O'Brien yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes and the chair
yes 18 years
all right the motion passes 18-0 is
there any objection to consent
all right seeing none I will put this on
consent and I will write a committee
and we have 15 minutes before our next
hearing so
take a break
okay
ah
if he he drives the uh the other car
that that'll get him through the tolls
on his wallet oh yeah I got thrown for
Turbo because before the amendment am I
supposed to have a separate sheet but I
didn't yeah I didn't get one
it's on the page but she never
see see that there's no
but she didn't give me a sheet for it so
but oh well but I was like oh we're
doing two floats and I was like oh but I
relative to the filing and Adoption of
proposed administrative rules I would
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee I'm Carol McGuire Merrimack 27
which is the towns of Allenstown
Dunbarton Epsom and hooksick House Bill
358 is a number of changes to the
administrative rule process that was
requested by the committee and the
committee's staff
and
most of it is to simplify or clarify the
procedure
there is one
um
one substantive change
which is on page one starting line 22.
which is to improve legislative
oversight by sending a new rule in
incorp implementing new legislative
Authority
to the policy committees that deal with
that that passed the law that created
the rule
so that if
we were to pass a change to a licensing
law
we would Edna would in the House and
Senate would get a copy of the of the
rule
in order to confirm that the rule
uh that's a change there's
um which has been asked for by a lot of
people
and
a lot of cleanup of issues that have
come up in
various gel car meetings and Rule Rule
reviews and
um
just to make sure that we the rules
don't get in the way of everyone doing
their own work
for example on page four
the
the response of a board or commission to
a
committee objection
is seven days after its regularly
scheduled meeting
or instead of for instead of two weeks
after the uh the meeting of jail car so
that they don't need to call an
emergency
board meeting in order to address the
rule
and I will try to answer questions and
there are
other people here who know more about it
yes representative Lucas
okay my question uh is on the sentence
at the very bottom of page one going
into page two the chair of the standing
policy committee
receiving proposed rules shall review
the proposed rules in consultation with
members of the standing policy committee
my question is what does in consultation
with the members of the policy committee
mean is that a committee meeting a vote
what is it
it depends
if for example we were to receive such a
document now
we would have a committee meeting on it
in somewhat like an executive session
and make a committee recommendation if
it were to be issued on Halloween
it would probably come to me and I would
I might talk to some people that I think
are likely to be real re-elected
but it would be a much less formal
process
and the and the difference in access to
the legislature between the when we're
actually in session when we're not is
follow up follow up yeah I'm a little
uncomfortable to vagueness
um you know I don't know just how it
would be worded to make it clearer but
to at least if possible have it uh have
there be a requirement that
there'd be a meeting and a vote
um and then the other part of that is
what's the time frame on this between
um
the proposed rule change and when the
committee would have to I think there
was a date
um
it's on line 13 the end of the public
comment period
and they do in fact read and respond to
public comments they don't always adopt
any other questions
representative Cody yeah
so
I support the bill
my own so and I think it would be
helpful for the committee
if they knew
how many rules
are generated as a result of legislation
that
I don't know myself but there's expected
to be several hundred this year
and part of it of course is that it was
10 years ago that we extended the life
of a rule to 10 years
and so they're all coming due at once
um
you can ask the staff they know better
than I do the exact count
follow up follow up I just although I
recognize
um
maybe you can speak to the practicality
of having the committee review all the
rules
well right well this is only new rules
right so that for example if they're
it would be because of new legislation
and presumably
the committee
would still remember what they what they
had in mind
but if you're looking at an existing
rule that's being tweaked
as it's being renewed it's rather
unlikely there'll be very many people on
the committee that would remember what
they passed 10 12 years ago thank you
yes representative Lucas just to clarify
in that case this bill wouldn't require
the committee to look at it because it's
not a new rule correct all right thank
you
anybody else
uh yes representative goalie
thank you Mr chair
if the committee sends back their
recommendation that the rule does not
meet the intent of the statute what
can happen
well since it since the rule
is in the public comment phase
my expectation would be that the rule
would be substantially revised to comply
and if not
I'm sure that if any committee
replied that the rule doesn't meet
legislative intent they would be keeping
yes representative
thank you Mr chair
um
I
conscious of objections that we
constantly heard at jalcar that the
process takes a long time
uh and appreciative of the fact that in
fact it does take a long time because
it's an important process
however I do see this
process as possibly even lengthening the
period of time that it takes to get
rules adopted
are you referring to the sending the
specifically yeah I it might but
more I would more expect that if there
are issues since the committee has to
respond in the same time as the public
that the the
agency would be getting those comments
back at the time they're expecting to be
revising the rule anyway it may take
them a little longer or they have to do
a total rewrite if they were in
opposition to the legislative intent
but this is a period when they're
they're looking at the rule and revising
it because of the public comment uh it
shouldn't add that much it's not a
separate cycle it's a parallel input to
follow it follow up
um am I understanding
the language correctly that uh the
policy committee that these would be
submitted to would be determined by the
speaker and the Senate President is that
um let's see who art says
as defined in RSA 541a
Roman 16 which
I
but I'll take a look at who determines
okay standing policy committee means a
committee listed in the rules of the
house or the Senate to which legislation
including rulemaking Authority was
originally referred for hearing and
Report
so
it would be the committee that actually
passed the
recommended the bill that
and
um yes go ahead
now my brain has forgotten the other
question
oh thank you um
follow-up question thank you
um
was consideration given
uh to possibly stating that the minority
a minority member of the committee
uh
I can't speak to the exact language but
the minority is a member of the
committee and would be consulted along
uh yeah just one kind of I think
following on what representative was
just saying because it is a little bit
open-ended and we don't know exactly who
will be involved at any given time
whether we're in session or out of
session
who determines who can give feedback
to the any member of the public can that
is interested can give feedback to the
agency on a rule so we're not we're not
looking for any particular hierarchy
within the committee to run it through
they can just go directly to the
as written it just says that the chair
is responsible for making sure that any
comments get to the agency
and if any member of the committee
gets newly appointed or whatever they
can easily respond as a member of the
public which is legitimate
um and I will say that the
that random Representatives comments on
rules are given quite a bit of respect I
put some comments in on the driver's
license's licensing rules last year and
they completely rewrote the section that
I was concerned about not quite what I
wanted but a lot better than it was
um so
any other questions
thank you representative I think we're
all set there
um the chair will call Representative
Schmidt
before you begin representative Schmidt
if anybody else is planning on
testifying if they wouldn't mind filling
thank you Mr chairman
okay so uh
I I've served on the gel car for 16
years
um during that time I think I've missed
one meeting so I'm not an occasional
visitor to the committee process
I've been there I've also been the vice
um I I think the this bill is well
intentioned but you have already and
with some of your questions even though
most of you ex as a matter of fact
except for representative schwart I
think none of you have been on the gel
car uh other than me I'm sitting over
here but even uh without having served
you've already kind of sensed and and
and started to address some of the feet
of clay of this bill
well intentioned or not in my opinion uh
this is
um kind of a Rube Goldberg machine you
all know what a Rube Goldman machine is
well I look it up on your on your cell
phones or your apps as we're talking and
you'll see it's a device that goes
around you know it's kind of like going
from here to Boston by way of Los
Angeles uh you can get there but you
wouldn't do it under almost any
circumstances so
um this this concept even though it's
been worked on by the
administrative rules unit up on staffers
in in the interim
um and it it it is of questionable
workability at Best in my opinion and I
think it's also to some degree
um a solution in search of a problem the
gel car is not perfect and I'm not
saying it is
but it's been in place for what 30
30 years Mike
1983 17 and 22 makes 39 I believe okay
so almost 40 years and
um and I think it works pretty well it
has lots of uh of skilled attorneys over
the years and I've worked with uh this
group but also the people who proceed to
them and some of the people who preceded
them in my 16 years on the committee uh
and and and there are four of them to
vet the rules
um and uh currently and uh and I think
that
um it it is one of the specific aspects
I want to address is the idea when you
have a a situation when the legislature
is out of session
in other words the Committees are not
really available or it's not supposed to
be any legislative work in July and
August for the new those are new uh
speakers generally have been saying no
legislative work in July and August and
the committee doesn't usually start
meeting until maybe October uh to look
at retained bills and so forth and so on
so for more about six months of the year
the Committees are not there which means
now you're going to have to confer with
the chairman if he or she is available
and then that person is going to try to
confer with medicine member members of
the committee if they're available what
about if you've got a divided committee
I think somebody asked a question in
this regard earlier what if you got a
divided committee then the question
becomes well what is the intent of the
rule that's one of the chief pillars of
gel car we uh a rule cannot exceed
legislative Authority that's one of them
and the other main pillar of the gel car
process is it's not it cannot be
contrary to legislative intent
and that's what these people do
they look at the statute or they look at
the existing rule if it has to be
re-adopted and they try to Divine I use
the word intentionally uh because it's
kind of God like to determine what
legislative intent is above and beyond
what the words are because of course
there's also a legislative record that's
supposed to tell you how the committee
got to the
the rule they've recommended right
that's what it works on we look at the
rule we talk about it we mull about it
we have a subcommittee on it we we uh we
try to come to a Unity between the the
one party and the other to some degree
but also in terms of
um what the best way is in many cases to
try to determine how many angels are on
the head of that pin or you know exactly
which way you're going and it's a lot of
hair splitting going on sometimes as
those of us who have been here for a
while can attest so uh now going back
and trying to determine exactly what
legislative intent is above and beyond
what the plain language of the statute
is sometimes it's very clear that's what
courts are all about
um and that's why it's what they come up
with is called an opinion for one thing
uh and so this is I I think it as I said
it's kind of solution in search of a
problem uh and it's a very very much of
a Rube Goldberg device look it up if you
haven't already and you'll get my sense
it's not that it couldn't possibly work
the question is
are the are the
the possible frailties of gel car are
they such that we have to create this
kind of
little Goldberg device this rigmarole
this you know seven ways around the
corner to try to get a better result
than we're currently getting without any
changes at all
so I'll leave it with that and you can
ask any questions if you got
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for sitting in the hot
seat
that's why I'm here you don't have to
thank me
so
you don't
believe
the committee that passed the
legislation should at least be apprised
of the rule that goes along with that
piece of legislation should be vetted by
that committee that passed passed it
they vet the statute that's their job
they vet the statute the jail card then
sorry the administer first of all it
goes to the agency right for rule
writing and the agencies are where the
practical knowledge on the part of the
state is right and there's kind of a
back and forth to some degree between
the administrative rules unit attorneys
and the rule Riders
to to work something out then you have a
public hearing where the public has
another chance to weigh in on the rule
whether it's workable or unfair or goes
off the rails or whatever and there's a
negotiation back and forth until you get
to the point where the attorneys either
say now the rule meets the statute it
does its job
okay in which case it goes before the
gel car and goes on the consent decree
if it's if the rule is unobjectionable
and if it's on the consent committee on
the consent calendar any member of the
jail car can pull it off just the same
way we can pull a rule off a statute off
that's uh in the process of being
addressed and built voted on in in plan
a recession of the legislature uh but
um uh if it's on the consent calendar or
nearly goes through because eternities
have said this rule Works in terms of it
doesn't exceed legislative Authority it
doesn't violate legislative in the
process yes follow up follow up
so then why
why would you be opposed to the standing
committee seeing the rule to review it
and at least if they so choose
have a comment prior to the public
comment session
why are you opposed to that
well the public comment section is not
the only bite at the Apple that's a
public has after the rule has been
worked out it goes to a public session
okay a public hearing then then my
question is why are you opposed to the
standing committee
having a look at the rule to make a
comment if they so choose before the
public session is done
because they've already they've already
participated in their part of the
legislative process they've come as
close as they can to perfecting the rule
and the the the bill in the time
available and after and the rules only
supposed to implement it
that's that's its job there is a public
commentary before the rule is cut even
comes to the gel car
and when the attorneys sign off on it as
I said if they consider it okay and does
its job goes on the consent calendar if
they have any issues whatsoever
where they say we're not comfortable
this only the gel car can determine
whether we're going to let this rule go
go forward and that's a majority vote if
there's something that's wrong with the
with the rule the gel car can have
what's called a joint resolution
which then has to go before both bodies
and has to be adopted by the legislature
because we don't have pocket vetoes in
the state of New Hampshire no committee
can pocket something in and take it away
only the Full House or the full Senate
has a say on whether something passes or
not it's a system that's flawed like
anything human but it works pretty well
if you have a competent legislature to
it and a competent Governor to adopt a
good a good law and we know those of us
who've been here for a while that there
are statutes that get adopted
and enacted over Kicking and Screaming
of sometimes half of the legislature
that doesn't want it
and then it depends on
you know whether the governor will sign
it or let it become law it's still a
very fragile process in many respects
but it's the best thing
thank you
any other questions
so I I'm just telling you
it works pretty well the way it is and
this is gonna
screen at the at the at the joints to
try to make the situation better than it
is now in my opinion I don't I don't
think this is as as much work has been
done on it I don't think this is ready
for prime time
thank you very much representative
um the chair would like to call the
director of administrative rules from
and do you have any testimony or just
answering questions uh basically just
answering questions okay for the record
my name is Michael Morrow I'm the
director of the administrative rules
unit within Opera office of legislative
Services I've been working for the unit
for 30 years
if you can director and thank you for
joining us um just to clarify maybe some
of the questions that have been circling
around
um
this paragraph that's been under
discussion it's intent if I'm correct is
that the members of the committee would
just be apprised of what the rule is so
that the members could weigh in on any
concerns that they have with how it's
been constructed and as to whether or
not it meant the original intent correct
it doesn't it doesn't affect its ability
to move forward we're not vetoing it or
we're not giving it an up or down that's
correct
um it's if there's new legislation and
then there's a rule to implement that
legislation it would go to the policy
committee to take a look at to see if
they think the rules actually implement
the statute correctly or if it's going
into creating a new policy
Etc then the uh the policy committee
would report back to gel Carr and gel
car would take that under advisement
so
if
the members of the committee aren't a
prize aren't aware of the rule aren't
able to give feedback ahead of time then
the rule will be set and that rule
without any input will go to jailcar and
that's what gel car is going to
basically interpret the agency would
initially put in what's called an
initial proposal they draft up the rules
and say this is what we want to do then
they have their public hearing process
they may get testimony or not from the
public it may be a little maybe a lot
they also get comments from my office on
the initial proposal we're required by
law and by the committee's rules to
advise the committee of any potential
basis for objection there are a lot of
instances where it's a minor thing in
the committee
decides it's not worth objecting to or
they get an explanation from the
agencies saying why that rule is written
that way
but uh that is a process
not seeing any thank you very much for
joining us thank you did any other
member of the public wish to speak uh to
seeing none I will close the public
hearing and we are in recess until one
o'clock
uh Mr chair
I believe it's the intention of our
chair that this will go I'm sorry yes
this will be um referred to the
subcommittee on rules representative
welcome to udna I'm opening the public
hearing and House Bill 274 and I call
foreign
good afternoon
my name is Lori Sanborn and I represent
the beautiful town of Bedford
a group of us sponsored Hospital 274 in
an effort to reform rulemaking processes
and make our state much more friendly to
New Hampshire small businesses
I'm a small business operator myself and
was the founder and chair of the New
Hampshire house business caucus for many
years here and as a group we held
numerous round tables with businesses of
all different sizes across the state to
get their input on ideas and over and
over we heard the same feedback that the
excessive regulations and the red tape
in our state is overly burdensome and
makes running running a business here
quite frankly very hard and very
frustrating
so I've been contacted more times than I
can count by irate small business owners
who yell at me for passing a bad Bill
and it comes to turn out we look at what
it is what the situation is I stare at
them like a deer in the headlights and
then we do the research and we realize
it wasn't a bill that we ever passed it
actually was a rule that was implemented
and now someone's coming to make sure
they're complying with that rule and no
one really even knew about that rule
just this past summer I was contacted by
a New Hampshire farmer who suddenly
found an inspector at his doorstep
trying to looking for a new license and
a whole new compliance and again this is
a situation they were complying a new
rule we never passed a bill we never
passed a policy on the issue but there
was a rule that was being enforced and
of course exposed this business owner to
fear and fines
um another example
um I got a call from a large retailer
who was issued heavy fines for allowing
employees to purchase clothing
merchandise with his logo on it
now what we passed as legislators was a
policy that said if you require your
employees to wear a company uniform you
cannot make them pay for it which is
common sense but the rules went really
beyond that to extend it to any logoed
company merchandise and they got heavy
fines for that and had to fight that so
this is the type of examples that I keep
hearing about and as you probably know
rules created by government agencies
have the full force and effect as law
um and as a legislature we give you no
better than anyone we give this
rule-making Authority
and we understand that the agencies are
really just trying to clarify and
administer what we pass
but we just need to make sure that the
rules that they promulgate match the
scope and the intent of the policy that
we passed and sometimes we see that they
exceed them and I have seen personally
where a one-line change in an RSA has
turned into a book of new regulations
and literally reams of red tape which
can also turn into Hefty fines on our
small businesses
so when I always encourage business
owners to come and testify come come and
talk to us give us input give us
feedback give us feedback especially on
these rules when they're being
promulgated and most of them have no
idea about the process have no idea that
stuff that is directly impacting them
and their business and their industry is
coming up and Rule making they have no
knowledge of that and then the folks
that have knowledge honestly a little
bit they're afraid they're afraid of
retaliation
um so that's concerning
um what we're trying to do is make sure
that this bill ameliates that situation
by making sure there is no fear factor
of retaliation and that we encourage as
much input up front as possible in the
rulemaking process
particularly by incorporating the policy
committee that's involved
in that policy area so that up front
early on those are the people who
understand those rsas can weigh in on
the rule making process so it doesn't go
too far down the road and we find
ourselves with a lot more regulation
as you can see by the co-sponsors who
helped craft this bill which includes
speaker Packard Deputy speaker Stephen
Smith speaker Emeritus Stephen shurtleff
uh your chair she's around here
somewhere Senate President Jeffrey
Bradley and lots of other esteemed
representatives and Senators there's a
big group there is a significant
bipartisan concern about the hardships
our current rulemaking process imposes
on our businesses
House Bill 274 is truly a bipartisan
effort which is meant to improve the
rulemaking process reduce red tape
encourage more input to agencies and to
gel car early in the process without
fear
ensure that regulations proposed by
agencies don't exceed the scope or the
intent of the legislation we passed and
then if gel card does object to the rule
this bill would say it doesn't move
forward because right now as many of you
might know if Joe Carr opposes or
objects to a rule it still be goes into
effect and effectively becomes law
so this bill aims to stop that so and I
guess you know as a fellow legislature
my question to you is whose
responsibility is it to make law
I think most of us would agree that it
is our duty as state representatives and
Senators to make policy and this is
quite clear on our constitution
so in summary this bill attempts to make
reasonable reforms by reinforcing the
clear authority of lawmakers to create
policy by ensuring that rules do not
exceed the scope or the intent of the
original legislation and do not create
unnecessary or excessive burdens on our
state small businesses so we would
obviously appreciate your support and
yes representative true
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um on the uh
on the addition of
I won't be able to find it now we're uh
what kind of retaliation would they
suffer could they suffer and what
happens if that retaliation comes about
in spite of this bill
that's a good question and this
co-sponsors and I talked about this a
little bit is do we put you know what
happens if this retaliation how do you
enforce this and I'm not sure about that
answer but I can tell you I did go to
the state employee handbook and there is
a clause in there that talks about
employees should not retaliate so if
someone complains about you harass me
there isn't no retaliation Clause there
and I think
like most businesses you have to manage
that on a case-by-case basis to some
extent but I think it would give
the business Community citizens a little
bit more relief knowing that it's
expected that there would be no
retaliation and I have heard and who
knows if this is true or not but a
business has gone to testify uh and
critique rules and they suddenly get an
audit or an inspector and that we just
we we really want to make sure that
people aren't afraid to communicate with
their government so that's what this
I I have one um so you stated that with
this in place of gel car
um disagrees with the rule that it would
put a stop to the rule is that correct
yes what would be the next steps after
that
because assumingly they're they're
putting a rule into place because of a
statute that we've written is that
correct or is this well they they could
continually go back and and redraft it
okay yes so there'd be no limitations on
the number of redrafts until we got it
right
awesome yeah
foreign
colleagues
as haven't been before you for minutes
um so uh
so I would like to uh State my
opposition to this bill
and with all due respect again having
served for 16 years on gel car
I I would say uh it's already in our
mandates that
[Music]
um
a rule cannot exceed legislative
Authority
nor can it violate legislative intent so
if it's already in our mandates and our
rules that those two things cannot
happen
what would this bill do by stating it
again and kind of shaking its finger and
say but this time we really mean it
because if it's already illegal or
against the rule then making another set
of rules that say essentially the same
thing is a uh wish in
in place of uh promise because
uh if the current rules are being
flouted which I would deny that they are
uh because uh I have served and I've
seen very rarely a case where
um something which was clearly improper
under the rules and I will give you an
example in a moment uh I went through in
spite of the fact that it was prohibited
and so we had a bill I mentioned this in
committee some time ago but it's very
appropriate right now
that we had a bill to ban smoking in
restaurants and bars
um there was no authorization for any
kind of
uh punishment or fine but without the
hammer of a fine or punishment then the
statute could easily be bloated
and there would be no punishment
um so the agency recognizing that no
Hammer no compliance or at least you're
inviting contempt for the statute if you
have no sanction the agency put in a
fifty dollar administrative fine the gel
car attorneys immediately said in the
report when we were hearing that rule
that this is
without foundation in other words it
would exceed legislative intent
so what we did was we
mild age what's called a joint
resolution and that stopped that aspect
from going into effect
um and but the but the committee in the
house recognized that without the
sanction there would be no enforcement
effectively and so they said we're going
to give the state the authority to
sanction and they allowed they changed
the statute to permit a you know an
administrative fine because they
recognize that that otherwise it was
unworkable so
it represents Sanborn is speaking from
hearsay I think because I've been on gel
car for 16 years and and and in the
house for 20 years and she hasn't been
on on gel car in all those times so she
can't be speaking from experience
because I've been there the whole time
she's been in the house and she hasn't
been there so I can tell you for a fact
that the attorneys are enforcing the
rules of gel car and rules that do not
comply with the statute because they
either exceed legislative Authority or
they are contrary to legislative intent
there they do not go forward and even in
the time there is one aspect that she
may be represents Sanborn may be
referencing
um which deserves a moment of attention
I didn't speak about this in the
previous hearing and that is there are
two levels of stop signs the first one
is called a preliminary objection and
when a rule comes before us that has
some problem the attorneys have brought
it to our attention we agree with them
that this is improper we can there's no
there there's no Authority and and we
we're not going to permit that
then we file a preliminary objection the
the agency then has 45 days to come back
to us with a fix of that problem
or overwhelmingly uh they come they come
back within that period and they have
fixed the problem
and then the rule can go into effect
um if they don't uh then we can file
what's called a per a final objection
and in those cases the agency can
can
file the rule but
they are on their own if they do they
don't the state will not stand behind
them and the net effect of that is
agencies don't want to do that
they just don't they don't want to go
out there effectively with no State
backing and so in my 16 years I think it
is a final objection uh being
disregarded and the rule being
implemented has happened
I think maybe once maybe not at all in
16 years so these these strictures
can't exceed legislative Authority
cannot buy be contrary to legislative
intent they are real stop signs and very
rarely have we had a joint resolution I
gave you an example of one of the two
times I think and so
this this is not this is not a bill that
will work in my opinion it certainly
will not improve the situation gel car
already Works uh if you have a situation
where where an agency might overstep its
own rules
uh uh by being heavy-handed or something
like that
that's not something that fixing the gel
car process would address in any way
because if a if an agency is going to
violate the law
uh and they're going to violate the law
and no matter what the law says right so
this is not the case
um and uh and in any case if an agency
is heavy-handed then they can be sued
and they've and agencies are sued and
they're stopped with the court deems
that they have violated the statute so
I'll stop at this point and you can ask
any questions you may have
thank you any questions
representative true
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um you stated there were two types of
stop signs from Joker they're more than
two but they're two primary pillars
those are the ones I've cited several
times
there's a financial there's a financial
aspect but that's usually not the case
and and the and the fourth one is also
very infrequent the two that really are
the stop signs are can't exceed
legislative Authority it can be counter
thank you uh all right so the the
preliminary objection
you were saying stops the rule for 45
days the agency can rewrite the final
objection doesn't stop the rule
but
this bill would give joeca the authority
to stop the rule
I don't see that it could give gel car
well I think it would give the Joker the
authority to just the process as I see
it is an expanded process because
um there would be much more committee
involvement the rules would go back to
the Committees for them to weigh in on
whether something was uh in in improper
but as I said in my earlier testimony
what happens if you have a divided
committee a a bill narrowly passed the
committee you know by one or two votes
but it's still an ought to pass
it goes and it gets adopted by the other
body after passing the house uh the
governor signs it then it's the law and
I I think if you're going to say that
this law will stop it but that law won't
stop it I I don't accept that premise
although thank you it's not a
preliminary final objection is not a a
stop sign it says
you you are you are you are putting this
rule into into effect against our
recommendation
against our final objection but they
still have the authority if they think
because the agencies have certain
Authority and if they think they're
right and they're basically saying we
think the courts will will believe us
and not the not the gel car but and I'm
telling you in 16 years that has rarely
if ever happened that's important rarely
if ever happens
thank you but we as you read house bill
274.
it's giving Joker
a stronger
weapon to block a rule
I don't think that I I don't think it's
really stronger because if the agency is
going to defy the law they're going to
defy the law and then they need to be
thank you we could go
paragraph by paragraph and I could say
this is not unwise un unproductive thank
you representative any other questions
need to turn the mic on
um for the record I am Sean Jasper
commissioner of the Department of
Agriculture markets and food and I hear
in opposition to the bill
I've been on both sides of this I served
four years on gel Carr as a legislator
and after that I figured I had done my
Penance and could could move on to other
endeavors and I admire those such as the
previous speaker who has been there for
16 years
um
I understand fully the intent of the
legislation and I know the sponsors of
this bill very well admire them uh
as a member of gel Carr I worked very
hard with the leadership at that time to
make reforms and we did make a number
and this was back in the early 90s uh
the process was much worse back then
others will speak to the fact that the
courts have have determined that a
committee cannot stop a law from being
implemented so I think you'll find that
that part of it is not legal that only
the legislature can actually do that
because of the authority granted now
I'll tell you as a a department head
I would love nothing better than to not
have any rules to implement I have never
been before a committee and asked for
the power to create rules the
legislature is always pretty much said
well we like the idea of this law but we
really don't know how to implement it so
so you do the rules so I mean I think
that's a little bipolar to be now coming
back and saying yeah but we want to have
this Authority and I I don't think there
are too many department heads who
wouldn't say just write the rules into
the law if you can figure that out you
know God bless you you ask us to do a
very good a very tough job which
requires a tremendous amount of of Staff
time
but I'm going to speak to some specifics
in here on uh
page two uh
line 27 it talks about legislation that
was voted on by the committee
many of our rules go back decades and I
would suggest that in some cases every
single member of a committee who put
forward the Authority for us to adopt a
rule is probably long deceased let alone
no longer in the legislature so you're
giving a lot of authority to a committee
that didn't hear the initial
proposal for the law to begin with
and then giving them the ability to to
interpret what that legislature intended
many decades ago
if you move on to page three
um starting really on line two the
agencies shall verify that the rule does
not exceed the policy or intent of the
statute there's only one legislator
whose head I've ever gotten inside of
and that was my own
um I will never sign
such a statement saying that I know what
the intent of the legislature was unless
in very clear terms legislative intent
is part of the statute
otherwise it is left up to
interpretation as to what the intent is
and I'm not going to verify what someone
else some years before
um verified so we'll just stop doing
inspections we'll stop collecting fees
because our rules will all expire
because as long as I'm commissioner I'm
not going to violate my own personal
ethics by making a statement that I have
no idea whether it's true or not I can't
do that
moving down to line 35 on the same page
a narrative stating the cost and
benefits to those affected by the rule
probably in most cases most businesses
would say there is no benefit to the
rule to them
rules are largely to protect the
citizens of the State of New Hampshire
and so again how would I possibly do
that when I don't believe that the rules
were passed for the benefit of those
we're regulating
go on to line one of the next page
include an estimate of the cost to
implement the proposed Rule and the cost
to those affected adhering to the rule
again I could never possibly do that and
I would tell you that every business is
substantially different
um we have been enforcing the fisma
rules which
um have to do with food safety we could
either do it or the feds could do it and
everybody decided that the state of New
Hampshire was better doing that but I
can tell you in those Enforcement cases
that the cost to the businesses vary
greatly under food safety modernization
we had two cases last year of listeria
and apples the end result was
one Farm had to replace their entire
packing Lobby line because it was put in
back in the 50s and could not be
modernized others simply did sanitation
work
and so costs are going to vary I could
not do that I wouldn't submit rules with
that
moving down to line 20
that the notice of period shall not end
before the submission of the rule I
think this is highly unfair to the
agency and to perhaps those who are
intending to make comment because if
they come in at the very end
we couldn't possibly take those comments
into effect but you're giving them the
uh the false idea that if they uh
provide comment on the last day the
agency is going to be able to take their
comments into account that's simply not
possible there needs to be an end time
in the ability for us to take those
comments into consideration
moving on to page five line
12 through 14 again
that the the agency submit that
verification again can't do that
uh line
33 34 about retaliation that's a very
difficult thing
to measure I can tell you that people
have said oh they won't talk to me
because they're fear of retaliation even
though I have no ability as commissioner
really to retaliate against anybody
but if we go in and enforce the rules as
they are written would be easy enough
for someone to say this is retaliation
what does that mean how is that
investigated
you know what are you going to do to
verify that I think that's a very
slippery slope I think there needs to be
and I think there are ways for people to
deal with that people go to the
governor's office if they feel an agency
is retaliating and and that is the more
appropriate way to deal with that going
to the next page
um
pay uh line 12 for rules proposed by
board commission or an agency overseen
by a board or Commission
so I have an agricultural advisory
committee does this apply
they advise me
so they're overseeing you're requesting
elsewhere in here that a majority come
to the hearings that's not going to
happen they're a volunteer board that by
Statute is only required to meet twice a
year
um so that's that's a consideration
I'm moving on to page nine again same
same concern on line 15.
over to page
um
10 about the final objection and denying
the rule I've already spoken to that
others will as well
and
um
page 14 the reasons for
failures a majority vote for by the
house or Senate policy committee to deny
the rule that's a very dangerous area to
get into that's why you have gel car to
look at those these things again one
policy committee should not be allowed
to speak for for the body or the
committee that adopted the rule rather
it be two sessions before or 25 sessions
before that shouldn't be allowed to stop
stop the rule they can certainly come
make their objections to the committee
talk to the agency but that should not
be a reason for denying a rule uh with
that I will end my testimony and be
happy to take any questions
thank you any questions for the
commissioner yes representative Lucas
um yeah I mean there are some I I think
I'd have questions on but I know this is
going to subcommittee yes yes um if you
could
not looking for some long document but
maybe even a copy of this uh Mark or at
least a list of page and line numbers
and at least a brief phrase or something
indicating what your concern is about
each one so we can look at them
separately and
I can I can do that all right thank you
yeah thank you
anyone else
yes representative Hewitt
thank you Mr chair
um I have some questions but I think
they would be more directly uh to
someone representing gel Carr are they
anyone else thank you commissioner thank
you
oh sure I'm sorry
I'm sorry thank you
so
one of the concerns that I have when
um
jive with what the intent of the
legislation was
I suspect that in some cases it's
because legislation was written well
so
my concern for this bill is that it puts
the onus on rulemaking as opposed to
Clarity and legislation
can you comment on that please I would I
would agree with that and and many times
in statute it says commissioner shall
adopt rules as he deems necessary
so what does that mean how do how do I
verify that but those are in many
statutes as he he or she deems necessary
if the legislature wants more clarity as
I said at the opening my opening
statement then I think the legislature
needs to put that Clarity in and perhaps
write the rules themselves I would like
to make one other comment which I
intended to
um the sponsor indicated that an
inspector went to a farm so other than
Dairy sanitation all the inspectors will
go to the to the farm or from my agency
and I would encourage anyone who feels
that my inspectors are not treating
people correctly to come to me this is
the first time I've heard about this
this is very disturbing to me I'd like
to be able to address address those
issues because that is not something
that I ever want to want to hear about
and this is the first time I've heard
that because our our intent in going out
been dealing with with the people we
regulate is to help them comply with the
rules never to First threaten them or to
find them we understand the difficulty
of rules and so we're more about that
first time out there dealing with the
education of what you need to do to
comply and so I would very much like to
hear the details of that thank you very
much
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Henry Ahern I'm
from Plymouth New Hampshire and I have a
red deer farm in New Hampshire
the oldest Red Deer farm in the state
and the largest so I have had some
issues with rule making
some other things about me I am past
president of the northeastern elk
Farmers member of the live chairman of
the livestock committee at Farm Bureau
and a member of the North American deer
Farmers Association so I've been around
a while been doing this for 29 years on
my grandparents farm so the Barn's been
in I do rise in support of the bill
um a couple of stories as I go through
here
um
that that affects us as deer Farmers
which is a little unique than some of
the other Farmers I actually fall under
three
organizations now uh
Department of Agriculture which deals
with the health issues with the deer and
I have no problem with them and the
import licensing I think that's a good
job for them to be doing but then I also
fall under fishing game because I happen
to have deer now these are not deer like
the deer that run around in the woods in
New Hampshire which is their
responsibility but these are livestock
deer they're European Red Deer they will
not breed with our native deer so they
really don't affect the native deer
population
but I do have a whole set of rules
called the 800 rules from the fish and
game department
and I understand that they're being
Rewritten at the moment they're revising
them but I haven't seen anything of it
and nobody from Fish and Game
has contacted me about
any input
um which and then I also fall under
Health and Human Services because I sell
frozen meat and that's one of the rules
I
have been missing 29 years like I said
uh about nine years into it after
researching a lot about when what we had
to do to have a deer farm and be able to
sell meat
um
I ran into
a person from Health and Human Services
that said oh by the way now
we put into the rules a new category
called frozen meat
it had been there for six months or so
before I was anyone was notified and I
found out about it at a farm bureau
meeting
and nobody else in the livestock
committee or other people selling meat
had heard of it either
the
so there wasn't a fine but there was
certainly a discussion and I brought
that person in from Health and Human
Services to talk to the livestock
committee and talk to Farm Bureau but it
would have been nice before they came
and told me that I needed a license
which cost me a hundred dollars
and the meat that I'm selling
comes from a USDA Slaughter plant which
is another requirement of the state of
New Hampshire's Health and Human
Services not the USDA under USDA my meat
does not have to be inspected it's
what's called non-amenable species I
actually have to pay
seventy nine dollars an hour to have my
meat inspected
so it's an added expense on that the
license from Health and Human Services
cost me a hundred dollars a year
there's really nothing for it to inspect
I do get an inspector that appears once
in a while and we talk about my freezer
which is the only thing I have
they can't tell me what the temperature
is supposed to be the only comment I get
when I ask what temperature is Frozen
doesn't uh give me work to go on we have
so that is one of the reasons I think
there needs to be more input from the
public the licensees and even those of
us I didn't have a license at that time
so there would be no way for them to
notify me
but I am a member of The Producers under
the fishing game though the thing that
makes it really unique for what I do in
their rules is I have to have a license
not a big deal
now it gets expensive because I actually
have to do an annual report every year
of the number of deer I have how many
have died how many slaughtered there's a
report that I have to do I have to have
my vat
visit the farm
in the fall and say that my deer are all
healthy and submit a letter to fish and
game that cost me somewhere between 350
and 400 dollars
to have that happen
on with all the reporting I've got
fencing requirements
other issues with the 800 rules that
other Farms like a sheep farm or a
cattle farm don't have to deal with
so
more input into the rules is important
to me with fish and game and so forth if
you got anything else on my notes Here
uh
foreign
most of what I have uh I invite any of
the legislature that would like to to
come visit the farm
I've done several legislative tours
there and enjoy having you all visit
um and I'm available for any questions
thank you Mr Adrian any questions yes
representative Gayheart thank you
chairman
the well first off there's an elk Farm
actually it butts my property in Belmont
I don't know that one but it's pretty
cool seeing the elk every day
um question is had there been any
instances of deer escaping and causing
problems
um not escaping and causing problems as
far as I know the deer that I'm raising
are very much a herd animal and they're
very territorial
the hardest thing I've got is to
get them to go through Gates that I want
them to go through so I have to work on
that continuously because they like to
stay inside now if one wanders outside
because it's curious if I could just
stop yours it's not really a question
that's applicable to the bill itself so
I'm not gonna well if you want to follow
up with something but yeah being that
your game monitors your offenses that's
why I'll bring it up you said they
monitored the fences and so forth is
that what you were saying in your
testimony once again representative
Gerard
that's a it's it's an interesting aspect
of the conversation but it's not
particular to the build the bill doesn't
deal with fencing for for fish and game
that you're now required to take your
meat to a particular slaughterhouse is
that correct under the present time
under that license agreement it says
that it has to be USDA inspected me yes
okay I seems like I recall I'll follow
up sorry
it seems like I recall a bill a few
years ago that made that
um a mandatory thing and I honestly
don't recall if it passed was that what
affected you
um to have to do that
uh
I think it appears representative
McGuire representative Maguire
if I made that change was considered my
first term or my second and the it was
for regular farm animals particularly
cows and pigs not necessarily for deer
uh HHS is not involved in cow with cows
and pigs very much so I don't know where
this requirement the deer need to be
USDA slaughtered came from but
um
thank you for the clarification I I just
happen to remember that that bill came
through the legislature
there was a bill two years ago that
um Exempted bison
from some of the procedures to do that
at that time there was also elk and red
deer in the bill but that was struck out
the USDA meet was it's part of the rules
that go with my
license from HHS to uh
on frozen meat that it has to be
inspected
thank you yes representative goal
I just had a question I raise Angora
rabbits and I know there are European
based rabbit and and don't
um
is it pertaining to the bill itself
because we're not agriculture in terms
of
um the room making and why
um why he's falling under
fishing game
is
um
oh our diseases spread between the
red-tailed deer and the and the wild
deer here natives I'm sorry diseases
once again if I if I can start yeah I
don't think it really pertains to the
um I'm not sure that I can read the next
name I'll do my best for New Hampshire
dot Kathleen McCall hey
it kind of gets cut off Hampton
okay
thank you
Mr chair members of the committee
Captain Mulcahy hampson I am the senior
hearings examiner for nhdot and the
okay
thank you
um it's my privilege to appear before
you on behalf of the Department of
Transportation I'm here this afternoon
to oppose provisions of HB 274
um specifically the provisions that
repeal exemptions from rule making
specific to dot on page 14 line 31 we're
currently exempt from rule making for
Speed establishing speed zones and that
exemption would be repealed line 33
would repeal our exemption from
rulemaking for excavation permits line
34 would repeal our exemption from
rulemaking for driveway permits and then
on the top of page five it repeals
um an exemption I don't know that we
have for
um determining toll rates as far as I
know the total rate of tolls on the
turnpike system are determined by
governor and Council and it would also
on line 13 remove an exemption from
rulemaking for Easy Pass interagency
agreements I just want to go through
those um quickly one by one the driveway
um
permitting has been Exempted from
rulemaking since 1999 or 2000 there's
been a bill every two years for the past
several sessions to require that the
driveway permits be under rulemaking and
that's been killed by the legislature
each time
the driveway permitting is based on very
specific engineering standards it really
doesn't lend itself to rule making and I
can tell you if someone has denied a
driveway permit in New Hampshire and
they want to appeal that it would be
appealed to me as the senior hearings
examiner for the department and I
haven't had anyone appeal a driveway
Denial in the last at least 18 months
um before that time
um not very often did I handle an appeal
in terms of speed zones establishing
speed zones again
um
speed zones are established by Statute
and then what discretion the
commissioner of dot has for that
um is based on engineering standards and
again does not lend itself to rule
making I do have a letter for the
committee that was written by our
administrator of the Bureau of turnpikes
Bill Lambert it states the Department's
concerns more clearly and professionally
than than I can explain to you so I'll
just leave that for on regarding the
speed zones
in terms of excavation permits that
would be permits for when someone wants
to dig within the state's right-of-ways
again based on engineering standards it
involves federal regulations and doesn't
lend itself to rulemaking in my 15 years
as a senior hearings examiner I've never
had anyone file an appeal regarding
excavation permits
um and then lastly the exemption for
Easy Pass interagency agreements
um
dot is part of a Consortium of other
tolling States
um in regard to electronic tolling
um they come to agreements on what
requirements should be for the
electronic tolling transponders how to
deal with certain issues they work on a
lot of joint issues together I'm not I
don't have a number on the number of
States involved but it's more than 10
states that are involved in the
interagency Easy Pass agreement and I'm
I'm not sure how rulemaking would fit
with the actions that dot takes in
concert with so many other states I
again don't think it lends itself to um
rule making so I understand this is
going to a subcommittee and I would just
wanted to highlight the Department's
concerns with repealing these exemptions
I'm happy to take any questions thank
you any questions yes representative
thank you Mr chair um
s be available to join us in our
deliberations absolutely thank you
yes representative Lucas thank you and
again if you have or can create just a
list of the sections you have an issue
with and some brief comment as to what
it is since trying to remember these all
of these uh for the subcommittee is
going to be difficult I appreciate that
I'll get you something in writing
thank you very much thank you for your
time
good afternoon I'm Marty Mobley I'm the
legal coordinator at Fish and Game and I
had not intended to speak today we did
so much submit uh written testimony
electronically in opposition to the bill
but I just wanted to clarify and
reassure the committee that we do notice
and post our rules online as per RSA
541a requires us to do we did make
changes to our FIS 800 rules as mandated
by HB 1299 that was passed last year we
made changes
to those two existing roles as well as
adopted new rules to allow for an appeal
for a permit denial to import possess
release wildlife and these were posted
on our website they were noticed in the
rule making registered we had a a public
hearing and we were in front of Joe card
the rules have been adopted they were
approved by Joe Carr and they have been
adopted and the adopted rule is still on
our website so it is it is available for
for perusal and we did follow the
process that is spelled out in the
rulemaking manual for these rules
thank you very much
any questions
saying none thank you so much is there
any other member of the public that
yep
good afternoon my name is Daniel Cauley
from the McGrath Law Firm
um
we have been representing uh small
businesses and helping them grow in New
Hampshire for quite some time now
uh we're here to support this bill we
believe that it cuts through the red
tape we believe that it
um
it
simplifies the rule making process uh we
believe it safeguards the policies that
the legislature has already put in place
I believe the goal of this bill it stops
rules from distorting policy and that's
very important when we're representing
clients in the court because we're
dealing with the rules and we're dealing
with the statutes and somehow we have to
explain it to a judge
it stops making policy through the rules
um legislature has already made policy
it offers a constitutional approach to
approve or disapprove a rule that is in
place
I'll give you an example after covert
small business clients have been coming
up to us
they've been practicing they've been
licensed in the state of New Hampshire
for quite some time
well known in their industry for where
they practice
but they're confused because all of a
sudden there's a new enforcement action
either for because of new rules being
added or old rules being implemented for
the first time and enforcement action is
pretty scary because recently you know
we're looking not only I've seen not
only dealing with the agency fines
you're dealing with criminal court fines
and you're dealing well now with the
cost of uh they want the cost of their
investigation to be paid so
my clients are trying to be compliant
but they're confused between the rules
and the confuse between what the law
says and it's scaring away small
business owners in the state
um
I'll just give you a specific example
right now I'm representing I don't want
to go in too much detail because I'll be
in the in front of the Supreme Court
next month
but I'm representing a probably one of
the oldest Educators in testing
facilities in the state of New Hampshire
will particular license
very successful
um these devices he's a private third
party instructor
um historically what would happen is
they would go to these private third
party instructors they would create the
education materials they would create
the testing for and actually test them
and then they would go and get their
license there's never been a complaint
about this now all of a sudden and his
materials by the way are proprietary he
doesn't want to release them they've
remain safe on his facility I don't know
more than 15 years at this point there's
no rule change new rule change is that
now the state of New Hampshire wants him
to produce all of his materials and so
they can keep it on the lock and key in
their facility I don't know why that is
being even asked because there's never
been a security issue in the in the
there is it's not mandated by policy or
statute so that's part of the argument
we're going to be having and I think we
should keep in mind that boards and I've
sat on a healthcare board before I've
helped with the rule making I've never
got to the gel call level but
members change
on boards on committees and my client is
particularly concerned because sometimes
his competitors are sitting on on that
board and they will interpret the law
the way they want to interpret the law
not the way the law is read and that and
they try to you know make roles to
around what what that means so the
policy is not broken it's uh the rules
should not be making policy right and we
hear the term live free and die to me
what that means let's keep it simple and
let's don't complicate things that's
what New Hampshire is all about and
that's why I'm supporting this bill
today
if any questions or not thank you for
your testimony any questions
and could you do me a favor and um fill
no questions for you could you fill out
a pink card for me on the side table
fill out a pink card for me on the side
table thank you so much have a good day
you as well and do we have somebody from
Gel car who is willing to answer your
question
foreign
rules unit for the office of legislative
Services I did put in a card but it was
this morning during the other bill
um
I don't appear before you lightly
I've appeared like I did this morning a
few times to answer questions regarding
rules last year I spoke briefly on a
committee of conference tab but this is
the first time I've ever appeared before
a regular policy committee to testify I
don't like to do that I'm a legislative
employee but I'm not testifying either
on behalf or opposed to the bill I'm
just raising some concerns that we have
seen when we looked at it I'm concerned
that implementation of the bill would be
very problematic as it's worded now
hello
I am just going to
very generally discuss a few of the
issues if the committee would like I can
do a more detailed memo going over the
problems I've gone through it several
times and I think I wrote to about 80 or
90 questions and comments on the bill
something in writing would be helpful I
think okay
the first significant concern is the
fact the bill would allow either gel car
or a policy committee to issue a denial
of the rule basically kill the rule
right there
gel car was formed in 1983 the
administrative procedures Act was passed
in
1973. in 1981 there was a bill before
the Senate there was going to allow
committees to veto rules uh I apparently
there was concern about the
constitutionality of that so the general
court sent questions to the Supreme
Court and the Supreme Court issued an
opinion it was called
opinion of the Justice justices 121 New
Hampshire 552 that was issued in 1981
and they said essentially that a veto by
a single committee
is unconstitutional
yes the rule is because the legislature
has given authority to the agencies they
have delegated rulemaking authority uh
delegated legislation Authority
legislative Authority uh that can't be
taken away except by the entire
legislature so if there was a rule
forward gel Carr said no this is bad
we're going to deny it
that would violate the constitution
also under the bill there is a provision
where
before jailcar had up to 60 days to
review a final proposal after it was
filed
if they did not do it within that time
frame the rule was automatically
approved and the agency could adopt it
that takes out the bill takes out the 45
the 60-day limit
um
so
gel car could hold on to a rule forever
that would end up at some point being a
veto likewise with joint resolutions
joint resolution's been around a long
time about 20 years ago staff expressed
a concern because there were times when
jelcar voted to sponsor a joint
resolution but the joint resolution was
never sent to the legislature or the
legislature received one and then didn't
act on it well in the meantime the rule
cannot be adopted because of the joint
resolution
so it was just sitting there in limbo at
some point it becomes uh in fact a veto
of the rule
so that is quite problematic and the
Supreme Court cases directly on this
point
um
there are a number of major Clarity
issues there are Provisions that
there's new language that conflicts with
other new language or conflicts with
existing language in 541a
um there are a number of new terms that
are in the bill for example substantial
operational impact and excessive burdens
I'm not sure who's going to decide what
those means is it going to vary by a
committee to committee when they look at
um a major issue is that in a couple of
places in the rules in the bill it talks
about as the bill this morning did
when rules are adopted relating to brand
new legislation
and that's fine but there are many more
places in the bill that it doesn't talk
about new legislation that simply talks
about statutes or legislation that means
I think as was mentioned before you
could have a rule go to a standing
committee in the underlying legislation
was passed 30 years ago
is the that policy committee going to be
able to determine what legislative
there is also the concern about action
by policy committees when the session is
not in place
um there's no mention in the in the bill
um
there are several requirements that call
about say something to the effect of do
not exceed the policy or intent but that
language varies in about four or five
different places
it's small wording changes but it has a
dramatic effect
um
there is also a change right now uh gel
car
although the statute says may gel car
always looks at proposals by agencies if
there is a new rule proposed then gel
car reviews everyone It also says they
may look at already adopted rules if
they have a concern the bill would
change it to Shell for both so in
essence that would require a gel car to
go back and look at every single rule
that's been adopted which is
impossibility
um there are a few other concerns
right now gel carb May object when there
is one of the four bases for objection
um I think the reason that is in the
statute is because some issues become
before gel car that may be warrant a
preliminary objection but not a final
objection or
they receive comments from staff as I
mentioned this morning we're obliged to
notify by Statute we're obliged to
notify gel car of any potential basis
for objection I mean after 30 years here
I know that there are some rules that
they're not going to object to even
though it's a potential basis for
objection
that will be taken away so regardless of
how minor the issue
the committee will be forced to object
to the rule
that's why
20 years ago the conditional approval
system was created because before that
jailcar could only object there could be
a Minor error in the rule everybody
realized that it could be easily fixed
including the agency the agency wants to
fix it but the only option the committee
had was to enter preliminary objection
the agency had to go back do a another
full rule bring it back to the committee
they might have to wait two or three
months before the committee takes it up
because the committee's final proposals
take priority so the conditional
approval system was created where they
make the jail car says make this change
and they make that change and they don't
have to go back before jail car this
would essentially
get rid of that
um
the bill also requires all received
rules receiving a preliminary objection
to be sent to the policy committee
regardless of whether the basis relates
to legislative intent I mean legislative
Joe Carter kind of
um do it based on Authority in other
words is the rulemaking Authority for
the agency sufficient to cover the rule
they do legislative intent they do
fiscal impact statement is the fiscal
impact statement inadequate so all new
rules have to get a fiscal impact
statement from the LBA
and the final one is public interest and
you say oh wait a minute that makes gel
car a policy committee they're looking
at public interest well in the gel Car
Zone rules those are very very narrowly
defined it's Clarity issues is the rule
clear and understandable can it be
uniformly applied
was public testimony uh fairly heard
um
so there was that question uh there will
also be any significant increase in
rulemaking as was testified to by dot
there are 5.821 contains a long list of
exemptions uh from the rulemaking or
from part of the rulemaking process
these are by and large because it was
trying to fit a square peg into a round
hole the agency had to make changes in
response to federal law or state law far
more quickly than the regular rule
making process would allow so they
received an exemption or a partial
exemption uh all those agencies Housing
Finance Authority Etc will now have to
do a complete set of rules
also there is a requirement
in the rule in the bill that if one
piece of public testimony is received by
an agency
potentially even in support of the rule
then they have to the agency has to
create a draft final proposal and put
that out there for testimony and
delaying the process when there may have
no been no practical need for that but
the statute is written is rigid about
that
um this will I think expand the
rulemaking time frames right now on
average it takes about five months for
an agency to go through the rulemaking
process uh I think the other steps are
going to increase that I mean some
people think five months is too long but
they are doing lawmaking and as you know
bills don't go through very quickly less
than five months so there's no reason
the rule should either
uh
also the bill will require
in practice it would require substantial
uh redraft of the rulemaking manual that
is a manual that's put out it's approved
by the director of legislative Services
when amended it's approved by gel car
and it's about that thick and it
contains all the requirements that
agencies have to follow in drafting
rules and it contains the entire
procedure it fleshes out the statute
541a that would require substantial work
would take would take months I've
noticed that the bill would take effect
two two months after passage 60 days
foreign
regarding some of the other issues that
have been raised by the testimony there
was questions about the
clarity
the public policy excuse me
I told you about recent verses oh law
but the participation by the public I
think Representative Sam Barnes bill
take steps to it increasing public
participation part of the problem that
I've seen in the past is the public is
generally not aware of when a rule
affecting them is being proposed
currently
541a requires the agencies to post a
notice of the rulemaking in the
rulemaking register which is published
weekly by our office most agencies
especially the larger ones post a copy
of The Proposal on their website I think
representative sanborn's bill will
require that it be posted on the website
uh jailcar is authorized under the
statute to make
other requirements as far as public
participation I I've certainly seen in
the past where a rule comes before jail
car as a final proposal people show up
to testify and gel car often asks well
did you testify at the hearing before
the agency and they said no I just
learned about it yesterday
um
I can understand that maybe there needs
to be further clarification out there
but people also have a responsibility to
know the know the law you can't say to
the police officer I didn't know what
speed limit was here you're obliged to
know that
certainly in under existing law if you
are say a licensee or regulated by some
agency you can ask them whenever a rule
comes through that would affect that
person that they receive specific notice
from the agency when that rule comes
forward I think something like that
certainly can be helpful but maybe needs
to be more widely publicized
you know other than that I would take
questions
thank you for your testimony any
questions representative Lucas
um you referenced a couple times a
Supreme Court decision around the um
what a committee can and can't do could
you either uh provide that to the
committee or a pointer to it we could
find it yes uh I can cite it and then I
can obtain copies it's uh 121
New Hampshire
552.
and it was from 1981 and it's called
opinion of the justices
thank you
representative
thank you Mr chair
um
I did have a question
um on page four of the bill uh down the
section beginning line 28 about sending
notice to licensees
and I have concerns that this is
expanding the notices that would have to
go out to me considerably by U.S mail
have you looked at that section that it
seems to me that the addition of
operational or other regulatory licenses
expands the number of notices that would
have to be sent out
remarkably do you have do you have any
idea how you would even approach that
um
it does expand it
it's an open question as to whether that
would require a mail a copy to be mailed
to the person
um in the past this provision used to
say Michelle for any occupational
licensee
they had to receive direct contact this
was before email so they had to send a
copy of the notice they didn't send a
copy of the rule but now the notice and
the rule is generally on online and it
can certainly be emailed to all those
regulated to the extent the while the
agency must have the addresses and
probably emails of all the people they
regulate
follow-up follow-up thank you
um I'm also concerned uh Mr and Herron
testified that um
prior to the regulation Law whatever
created the need for him to have a
license he didn't know how they would
even notify him about a potential need
to have a license
and I'm concerned that how a gel car
even be able to find folks that may be
affected going forward I don't know how
gel car would but the agency involved
the agencies that regulate him it could
be more of a requirement like this does
put on the agency to notify people that
are regulated also people regulated can
look at the agent's website or request
us under current law that they be
notified when there is a rule that would
affect them
foreign
representative Gerhard
thank you John
the idea how many new rules are created
each year
um
there for 2022 we had 244 new proposals
that means initial proposals all those
rules then go to final proposals
um a third or more end up getting
conditional approvals so there's
numerous iterations 244 was the most
we've had in several years it seemed
like during covet we were down to around
150 but it has gone up we have had more
than that
most of those are not enacting new
legislation there may be rules because
rules most rules are only good for 10
years so when the time comes up they
either need to re-adopt them re-adopt
them with Amendment or if they no longer
needed to repeal them so a lot of the
rules come through that way other times
legislature makes a minor amendment to a
statute that's going to necessitate a
follow up
I'm just that's actually a much lower
number than I thought it would be but
I'm just concerned what you said earlier
about
ignorance of the law is no excuse and
that side of thing I just think of let's
say the IRS code at 60 something
thousand pages right no one knows the
law right no one does so I just don't
like putting the onus on taxpayers who
are funding us for being here to then
burden them with more things in order
for them to make a living it just seems
like a very vicious cycle of just
creating jobs for ourselves when they're
violating laws they don't even know
about yeah that's certainly a policy
consideration when looking at the bill I
mean as I said there could be strength
and requirements for the agencies to
notify to notify individuals that is in
part done by the bill
foreign
yes representative gold
so
the question was asked to be regarding
notification of licensees of rule
changes that you would have email
addresses on the existing people when
rule changes might affect them is that
correct at one time
agencies were required by mail to notify
the people and for somebody like the
Board of Nursing that has 30 000
licensees that was a pretty substantial
expense but now they can do it by email
the HR people can see it on the agency's
website one thing the bill does I think
I may have mentioned is requires all
agencies to post the rules on their
websites
so are you talking about you have that
information or the agency has that
information the agency I assume when the
person applies for whether it's a permit
or a license
would provide an email address and last
point now that I understand those things
in the case where you have someone who's
being impacted by a new agency getting
involved then you can expect that agency
to have that contact information correct
um
I guess that depends I mean if you do a
new board that's going to regulate some
sort of activity then they may know who
is currently practicing and might be
able to reach out to them or there may
be an association already in existence
which the members would belong to but
yes generally you're you're correct they
wouldn't know who they are
for example when Health and Human
Services wants to get involved in
licensing dear meat but they don't
they've never been involved with deer
they wouldn't have any way to know them
correct
thank you so much for your testimony
representative Maguire I'm assuming
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I'm a co-sponsor of this
legislation but
I don't agree with everything in it but
I believe that it raises a number of
issues that we should take seriously
one concern that I have is that
in my mere 12 years on on jail car
is that it's very difficult to get other
legislators concerned about what happens
in rules
they
they want to dump
uh
what the limit should be for various
items in water on the agency they don't
want to get involved in the details if
you tell somebody if you try to notify
people of a rule coming that you think
is in there
their scope
it is not uncommon for them to say oh
well you know Des will take care of it
or or whomever HHS will take care of it
and so this bill is partly to make it
easier for those legislators who want to
get involved to do so
and also to shake up some of the people
that don't seem to care and get them to
pay attention to the rules
because
the rules are much larger than the
statutes I mean we have one one little
bookcase that's got all the laws and I
have no idea how many pages of rules we
have but it's a lot more
and most people don't pay attention to
it even if they're in the legislature
and we end up with cases where
we hand over to the agency's broad
rulemaking authority to say just make
the rules we don't want to know the
details just do it and that's our fault
and I think one this is partly an
attempt to shake up the legislature and
say pay attention you're handing over
your responsibility of making laws to
these agencies and you're not keeping an
um so I'm that's why I supported the
build so I think
we all need to pay more attention to the
rules
and I think that getting the input of
people who know about the details of a
of a business or
whatever is very useful the attorneys at
gel Carr are very knowledgeable about
the law but they don't necessarily have
the context of every rule that they're
writing sometimes they're they're
reading sometimes they do sometimes they
don't and a lot of times if you don't
have the context you can look at the
role and say oh yeah that's fine
I'm I've done that myself I looked at
the role and then I said well yeah but
but I have a friend who who works in
this and I send it to him and he says
what are you doing it's ridiculous it's
going to be incredibly expensive because
he knew the details of what it was going
to do and I didn't
and so that's one thing
the New Hampshire legislature has got a
wide range of skills and knowledge
because there's so many of us and we're
not professional lawmakers we've that
we've done something else with our lives
so we generally have the context for one
or two or three or whatever
but if you don't look at it we can't get
the benefit of of that knowledge and I
really think we ought to get more people
involved and if this bill can do it
wonderful
uh
I've been trying
I will try to answer questions but I
don't really have the details
yes representative Grady
thank you so this goes back to the
question I think I had her I had spoken
I had asked um commissioner Jasper
so one of the
consequences of having a passing statute
or passing legislation or submitting a
bill well you don't know the
consequences the full consequences
is there a way of
doing that before
we get to that jail card process because
once the law is passed
so how do you you know I enjoy I applaud
what you're saying but at the same time
I'm trying to figure out how it is that
we can incorporate that kind of thinking
before we even we even passed the law
yes well that's what the public hearing
process is for and you know and we try
to get as many people as care to show up
you've noticed that rulemaking is not a
big draw for the common people
um but we try
the people who are working in rule
making
are here to to to inform you but the
people who will be affected by the rules
are generally not
and it's very difficult to figure out
who might be affected
by a new law
I didn't know that you know when we were
doing driver's licensing until
constituent told me that his Jeep wasn't
considered an agricultural vehicle even
though he was carrying fertilizer and uh
yes representative Garrett
thank you chairman would you be in
support of some sort of sunset provision
then on this to see if it works if it
doesn't then we just kill it and let it
die
um there's there's a lot to this bill
you know 15 pages there's a lot of
pieces some of them are
not workable some of them are
um
unconstitutional by by their nature
but because they record they allow a
committee to act with the authority of
the whole which is
not not allowed but there's a lot of
good ideas and I hope that we will we'll
take a look at it I was thinking about
the notification
and I would have no problem with saying
that you know when we Pat when the new
new rules implementing a new law are
being put out for public comment email
blasts the entire house and the entire
Senate and say hey we're these are the
rules that Implement house bill 148. if
you care look at the rules
I mean we should be paying attention but
any other questions
sure represent not representative Mr
Aaron
just the the most important thing I was
I think it's important in this bill
that the notification goes out to not
only individuals
but to organizations that support those
individuals like if the rule about the
frozen meat had gone to Farm Bureau and
they were notified then those of us that
it would have been affected would have
been notified if it's a forestry thing
or a land use thing it could go to uh
the Timberland Owners Association if
it's a restaurant food thing it could go
to the Restaurant Association so I think
those
ought to be important people
to be notified of these rule changes
that's what I had thank you for taking
me back again absolutely thank you
just one or two more things that I
didn't touch on before
as representative McGuire had talked
about uh Clarity of the underlying
statute and the rule-making authority
she's right some there sometimes there
are what we call Barn Door rulemaking
authorities say any provision to
implement this chapter or this
subdivision well that leaves it wide
open for the agency to say what they
think implements and it's very hard for
the legislature or for jail card to say
no that doesn't implement it I also want
to say it's very hard to determine
legislative intent with rules anyways
because the statute might be fairly
broad but rulemaking Authority and then
they're going to have to interpret it
for example legislature creates a new
type of license and gives the authority
to the agency to set up the application
process
well they're going to lay out a bunch of
things so they're going to create a form
they're going to specify what has to be
on the form they're going to perhaps say
what the fee is ETC
are those particular is any one of those
given items within the provisions of the
bill it can be very subjective to say
that
all right that being the case we're
going to refer this to the subcommittee
on rules and representative it's coming
your way and I'm going to close the
public hearing on 274.
and I believe that does it for us for